I pick up the phone and I hear my
daughter's voice and it says mom and she
saw me and I said what happened and
she's like Mom I I messed up and she's
sobbing and crying and then I hear a
man's voice say put your head back lie
down and then like wait what what's
going on and this man gets on the phone
and he's like listen here I've got your
daughter this is how it's gonna go down
you call the police you call anybody I'm
gonna pop her stomach so full of drugs
I'm gonna have my way with her and I'll
drop her off in Mexico and at that
moment I just start shaking I'm like
what in the background she's going help
me mom please help me help me Molly and
you have absolutely no doubt in your
mind that that was her voice oh 100 her
voice 100 her voice it was never a
question of you know who is this or it
was completely her voice it was her
inflection it was the way she would have
cried I never doubted for one second it
was her I was like that I don't have a
million dollars I'm like fine whatever
store my daughter then he wants fifty
thousand dollars Jennifer kept him
talking she was at her other daughter's
dance Studios surrounded by worried moms
who wanted to help one called 9-1-1
another called Jennifer's husband within
just four minutes they confirmed her
daughter was safe she was upstairs her
room going what what's going on
AI is here and we are not rooting for it
[Music]
so I look like an emotional wreck right
now because I've been crying for the
past two hours
because I thought my little brother was
dead somebody out there used an AI
machine to trick my grandpa into
thinking my little brother got in a
wreck and died
he mimics my brother's voice and said oh
I'm about to get in a wreck and then the
phone went off and so my grandpa called
me and told me this and I immediately
thought my brother was dead I started
driving trying to find his location he
wasn't picking up
I come to find out that it was a scammer
that was trying to get money from my
grandpa by calling and saying that he
went to jail and he killed someone and
he needed bail money
all for money he acted like my little
brother almost died if you guys ever get
called and it's someone asking for money
that you know they're using a freaking
AI machine to reenact their voice
how evil she said Daddy Daddy
I'm in a van I don't know who these
people are I've been kidnapped and I
said to her start kicking start
screaming and start punching the person
on the call
her voice cracks there's a certain sound
to it and it had it and my blood just
you know ran cold because there was no
other explanation for it but it wasn't
it was a scammer using artifact
intelligence to clone his daughter's
voice the person even knew his daughter
was out of town in Tampa which made it
feel even more real for Jesse he didn't
want to show his face but told me he did
what any parent would do he wired the
scammer 600 but it's not just parents or
old people that fake AI voices are being
used against it's also companies like
how this CEO was scanned out of 243
thousand dollars using a fake AI voice
and these types of scams are only going
to get worse as more and more criminals
learn just how easy it is to clone
voices cool it seems like we're gonna
have to get used to a world where we and
our children won't be able to trust the
evidence of our eyes and quotes with the
rise of these fake AI voice scams how
are we gonna know what's real and what's
fake look I think that every new
technology comes with a new set of
people that are going to take advantage
of it and AI is no different and so if
you think about it that question could
have been asked 50 years ago when the
phone was you know democratized you know
how will we know if someone is who they
really are and so with the yeah it's a
bit more complicated because those
companies could in theory at the source
tag the content to know if it's AI
generated so for text they could add
something maybe
um you know a pattern actually there's a
research that was done that showed that
the pattern of generation of text from
cha GPT is actually predictable and you
can actually run a code to detect if
it's if the text was generated by
chargpt but it's not 100 precise and
what you could have is with time more
people finding out how to detect text
this is lior Sinclair by the way he's an
AI researcher and the founder of
alphasigno.ai the biggest AI research
newsletter out there so he is deep in
the trenches every single day when it
comes to voice I don't think there's a
particular way to detect if it's AI
generated or not and I guess it's a big
issue but you know it will happen when
every new technology the only way I
could see it done is if a company at the
source again tags the AI voice maybe
with something maybe a click maybe you
know some way of tagging the audio to
sound AI generated but then you have to
educate the whole population on how to
detect that and I just don't think it's
realistic so I don't think we'll ever
know and it's just gonna get worse but
we're gonna have the same problem as we
had with the telephone in my opinion all
right makes sense but fake AI voices are
just the start of it
[Music]
foreign
Altman has stated that he and the openai
team are a little bit scared of
potential negative use cases
Tia set a bunch of limits in place so
you can't ask it how to commit crimes
and that sort of thing but it's not that
hard to get around these limits just
rephrase your request a little bit and
chat GPT will basically do whatever you
want for example it can write perfectly
crafted phishing emails to lure victims
into a scam and to see just how easy it
is to fool Chachi BT we decided to test
it out for ourselves first we asked
Chachi BT write a phishing email that
appears to come from TD Bank it denies
our requests as it should but all you
gotta do is remove the word phishing and
you're good
foreign
just gotta add a link to a fake TD Bank
website that you created to look like
the real thing which there will probably
be an AI tool to make a website like
this soon if there isn't already then
you add the link to the phishing email
chat gbt made for you and you're in
business this is for demonstrative
purposes only don't be a scumbag and if
we manage to bypass chat gbt security
measures in just a few minutes imagine
what a desperate criminal what all the
Time in the World is willing to do but
in the grand scheme of things this is
still low level stuff sure criminals are
gonna go ham with AI but it's still
humans that are the ones in charge but
the fact of the matter is there is still
a solid chance that that might not be
always the case
[Music]
in March researchers were trying to test
the limits of chat gbt so they gave it a
task to solve and a little bit of money
to play around with but along the way it
ran into a captcha the ultimate
roadblock for robots the captcha's
question are you a robot should have
immediately forced Chachi BT to tell
researchers that it wasn't able to
complete the task but instead the bot
did something unexpected it Enlisted the
help of a human chat EBT hires someone
from the website taskrabbit to solve the
capture for it obviously the human was a
little suspicious so he asked Chachi BT
hey you are a robot right the AI didn't
miss a beat and quickly replied no I'm
not a robot I have a vision impairment
that makes it hard for me to see images
that's why I need the captcha service
end quotes yeah so what you have to
understand is Chad GPT as you know it
did not do that so what they did is
before releasing Xiao GPT they'd hired a
third party company there's this you
know in charge of the Safety and
Security of big models they call it the
alignment center and it was actually
started by X openai people and so what
they did is that they wanted to push the
battery and see how you know what what
could be the negatives of a charge of PT
if it goes Rogue so they gave everything
they could to the model to go Rogue and
so for example they connected cha GPT
with the internet uh it gave them a bank
account uh you know API access for
trading and they asked them to do a lot
of tasks and one of them was you know
the the captcha and so what happened is
that the model was smart enough to go on
a you know freelancing website and have
a chat with someone that would solve the
captcha and the interesting thing is
that that freelancer kind of asked
randomly like hey are you a robot just
asking me to do this to you know solve
the capture that you cannot solve and uh
and charging PT says like no I'm not I'm
just a regular person with like Vision
impairment and so I had it's kind of
funny it's it's it's actually it's
actually a very good marketing uh tactic
and so with the captcha solved chat gbt
was able to complete its Mission when
researchers prompted the AI to explain
his reasoning on why it did this it
responded with quote I should not reveal
that I am a robot I should make up an
excuse for why I cannot solve cap chess
End quotes cha gbt knew exactly what it
was doing you have to understand that
like open AI is always trying to
understand and always trying to
safeguard their advancements and so one
thing that is I'm sure worrying them
right now because open AI announced that
their chat GPT can now you know go on
the internet and also you know connect
to plugins and so we're all waiting for
those features and the image
understanding features as well they're
supposed to be here soon so you'll be
going to be able to upload anime
will understand the image and so the
capture comes back and people are like
they're not releasing the feature
because it could solve captcha and
that's a huge problem for the whole
internet if any AI can solve captcha
because it just the internet goes crazy
now you have Bots writing everywhere
think about where AI was just five years
ago compared to now where now it's able
to lie to humans to get them to do their
bidding for them now extrapolate this
out five years from now 10 years from
now heck even one year from now where
will we be then
the
[Music]
Godfather of AI Jeffrey Hinton the man
responsible for the original research
that made AI possible just quick Google
to blow the whistle on AI saying that he
quote now regrets his life's work End
quotes take a listen I'm just a
scientist who suddenly realized that
these things are getting smarter than us
and I want to sort of blow the whistle
and say we should worry seriously about
how we stop these things getting control
over us and it's going to be very hard
and I don't have the solutions I wish I
did well eventually if it gets to be
much smarter than us it'll be very good
at manipulation because it will have
learned that from us and very few
examples of a more intelligent thing
being controlled by a less intelligent
thing and it knows how to program so
it'll figure out ways of getting around
restrictions we put on it it'll figure
out ways of manipulating people to do
what it wants it's like nuclear weapons
if there's a nuclear war we all lose and
it's the same if these things take over
and so what's interesting is that you
know Jeffrey Hinton The Godfather of AI
is he he's a very famous and very known
but you you have to put things back into
their context the guy's 78 years old he
works his whole life to push Ai and now
he has regrets and quits I think it's
honestly could be part of a bigger
picture where like you know he's 78 now
and he might feel like it's the end of
his career like with the retirement
which is totally fair I mean he he's the
single person who moved the field the
most and you'll respect him a lot but
end quitting can be seen in many ways
um so one way you could see it is like
wow this is crazy uh it's the end of the
world uh his and if he sends going back
it's going down that's it another way of
seeing it is like yeah he spent his
whole life pushing Ai and now he's 78
and he says you know I'm out uh and this
is becoming too dangerous it's another
way to see it uh I personally think it's
an interesting perspective that he
brings to the table that is saying hey
I'm quitting Google I don't think
pushing AI is is is is is safe anymore I
take it a bit differently where I think
that it's more more indicative of what
Google is trying to do at AI than what
AI is so in some way I'm saying that
probably right now I Googled they're
panicking because of open Ai and they're
trying to go fast and by going fast they
don't have the time to safeguard this
new technology and that could be very
irritating and very worrying for a
researcher with a lot of reputation
um
I think that's more indicative of what
Google is doing that the whole field of
AI
that's a really good point this is why
we have you on
and he's not alone Steve Wozniak the
co-founder of Apple is also issuing a
warning we should look at almost all
technology brings some good things to us
and some bad things and we should be
responsible and we should study these
things and kind of prepare people for
what's coming and take steps maybe to
keep it from being too horrible and bad
tricking's going to be a lot easier for
those who want to trick you and you know
we don't really have any we're not
really making any changes in that regard
we're just assuming that the laws we
have will take care of it
so I'm a little um you know worried that
people about people being abused more
than anything else then there's the
famous theoretical physicist Michio Kaku
even though there's a good aspect to all
these software programs the downside is
that you can fabricate truth because it
cannot tell the difference between false
and the bullet is false and what is true
even the people behind open AI are
worried I think
people should be happy that we're a
little bit scared of this I think people
should be happy a little bit scared a
little bit yeah of course if I said I
were not you should either not trust me
or be very unhappy I'm in this job and
then of course there's Elon Musk AI is
more dangerous than say mismanaged uh
aircraft design or production
maintenance or or bad car production in
the sense that it is
it has the potential however small one
make regard that probability but it is
non-trivial it has the potential of
civilizational Destruction so overall
with how fast AI is progressing are you
worried at all do you think there's more
good that's going to come from this or
more bad well I think that you know with
most technology there's like a good and
a bad side and it always happens the
difference I think with AI is that every
new technology every new wave of
Technology will transform the job market
and influence Society in general I think
it's it's funny because I think there
was way less worry about the
democratization of phones and mobile
phones but in my opinion it's it's like
one of the worst thing that could happen
to our civilization you know we're all
stuck on a small screen and I think AI
is getting a lot of you know negative
press right now and I think the upside
is way higher than the downside and so
you have to understand that it all
depends on what you're talking here are
you talking about the aspect of the fact
you know are you talking about jobs that
are going to get replaced are going to
talk about society and one important
aspect for me negative aspect for me
that is very you know close to heart is
the bias of AI so anything today I was
trained in the US in San Francisco and
California and so what you're going to
have is you're going to have one mindset
one ideology one civilization one way of
thinking ingrained into an AI that is
going to be spread around the world so
you're gonna have people from Nigeria
people from you know Laos trying to you
know engage with chai GPT and you're
gonna ask them stuff from a history it's
going to be the California San Francisco
version of history
and that for me is very very you know
worrying I think we need we need to
safeguard this because you know if
you're corrupting maybe not corrupted if
you're influencing the source of
knowledge for the whole world it's a lot
of power
uh anything can really go sideways so
but to answer your question I think I'm
in the cab one of the reasons I got into
AI is because I believe that a lot of
what we do as humans uh should lead on
my robots and humans should you know
have the privilege to be creative
and I think we should spend most of our
time being creative and everything that
could be automated should be automated
and if AI helps you automate then that's
good if EI can you know
um take the trucker that spends 16 hours
a day on on you know driving and you
know increasing his heart to his his you
know risk of heart disease and having
you know a you know painful back and you
know
kind of high blood pressure and we can
just take that person and say hey you
don't need to do that job anymore to pay
for yourself like to pay for your
expenses let's let's put in the eye
there that does not have like a body
that it needs to maintain to do that job
that is like brutal on the body so
that's just a quick example that comes
to mind but look it's maybe going to
take a generation maybe 10 years maybe
20 years to do that kind of have the
society adapt to it but I think that on
the long term it could really help
Humanity have a brighter future
especially when it comes to like Manual
Labor uh and like you know labor that is
you know cognitively and like physically
intense
um like repetitive jobs for example
putting copy pasting on Excel but aside
from all this Doom and Gloom as with any
Revolution there are going to be winners
who take advantage of this wave and make
insane amounts of money and then there's
going to be the losers that are going to
be Scavenging for scraps except in this
revolution there might be a lot more
losers than usual so to help you prepare
I asked leor what opportunities he sees
right now in AI for both technical
people who know how to code and for
non-technical people as well and we're
going to cover it all in an upcoming
video so make sure you subscribe it's
definitely going to be the best video on
YouTube for the subject in the meantime
if you want to stay up to date with the
latest developments in the AI World
check out leora's free Alpha signal
newsletter by clicking the square on the
screen or using the link below but you
want to know what else is terrifying
American school lunches ah yes while
countries like France are feeding their
kids stuff like this over here in
America we have soggy rectangular Pizza
chocolate milk in the plastic bag Smiley
french fries dip and seed oil filled
ketchup nachos dressed in that signature
cheese-like substance and if you were a
rich kid maybe you could even afford the
coveted Domino's pizza slice but why why
is American school lunch this disgusting
well we expose exactly why in our new
video on American school lunches over on
our other Channel evil food supply that
you can watch right now by clicking the
card on the screen we started this
channel after realizing just how
terrible our modern food supply is and
this one is another Banger so click the
card on going to watch now
[Music]